as one of the original Encana x-men back
in 1963
Cyclops had a ton of potential he's
always been a key member of the mutant
squad and his eyes can basically punch
things so you think that would warrant a
little more respect around the Marvel
Universe but comic book writers have
done a pretty great job of making Scott
Summers Marvel's most hated hero let's
take a look at the many ways of this
mutant leader went from being kind of
cool to kind of a creep a lousy lover
Cyclops has a pretty awful history when
it comes to how he treats women whether
it's his girlfriend cloned wife or just
some random swamp floozy he's trying to
move on with when he believes his
longtime girlfriend Jean Grey is dead
from a volcanic explosion in uncanny
x-men number 113 what does God do he
gets over his grief pretty quick and
starts dating Marvel mainstay Colleen
wing then Cyclops straight up dumps wing
when she finds out that Jean is still
alive and proposes an uncanny x-men
number 136 but Jean dies again as the
Dark Phoenix an issue later by issue
number 144 he's back at it with some
lady in Florida named Allie Forrester
vulture called add up to bad dating
habits but it gets worse
Cyclops marries his dead fiance's clone
Madeline Pryor in uncanny x-men in
number 175 and then he doesn't even
treat his clone wife well it's
eventually revealed that Pryor was a
tool in mr. Sinister's nefarious plans
but well before that revelation cyclops
had already started hanging out with
Jean Grey back from the dead for the
hundredth time after hatching from a
weird ocean cocoon leaving his wife at
home with Cyclops jr. aka Nathan summers
aka
cable Madeline does get her sort of
revenge hooking up with Cyclops brother
but coming the Goblin Queen and raising
some hell but when Madeline dies later
Jean Grey actually mourns harder than
Scott does for his own former wife and
baby mama and we can't even get into
which of these jean grades were actually
Jean Grey and which were actually the
Phoenix in Jean Grey form it gets
complicated anyway even after ditching
his family for a back from the dead for
real Jean Grey he decides his new
relationship is getting a little tired
since like constant death and
resurrection isn't spicy enough ever the
loyal lover Scott tries to liven things
up with some
telepathic therapy from Emma Frost who's
dressed up as Phoenix since he's married
to another immensely powerful psychic
gene quickly discovers his telepathic
tryst so what does Cyclops do he tries
to weasel his way out of it claiming
their liaisons didn't count because they
weren't physical and did we mention this
somehow he also found time to hook up
with storm and who the heck is this
maybe his eyes aren't the only part of
his body that he can't control maybe he
should invest in some Ruby quartz
underwear and that is why you fail as
husband material mr. summers work over
family being the unpaid leader of
Charles Xavier mutant squad is not an
easy job especially when humans mostly
just hate you constantly sometimes an
x-man just wants to get married settle
down and spawn an omega-level mutant or
two not Scott Summers though despite
getting married for the aforementioned
Madeline prior Cyclops have never left
his super villain battling life behind
continually putting the needs of the
team before the needs of his growing
family if Cyclops was the sole mutant
out there capable of paying it forward
that'd be one thing but the x-men and
the Xavier Institute are both
overflowing with butt-kicking mutants
like dummy and peak and globerman
anyway even storm confronted Scott at
one point over his dereliction of family
duties his response well he challenged
her to a duel of course and he lost even
though storm didn't use her powers
he built a murder squad the mutant team
known as x-force was always a bit rough
around the edges and often found
themselves at odds with both the x-men
and the government as well as the ante
mutants groups they battled none of
these problems were helped by Cyclops
being an extremely divisive leader in
uncanny x-men number 493 scott simmons
shows some early signs of being a total
fascist by reorganizing the team to kill
his own son cable as if tracking and
murdering your own kid wasn't bad enough
he took the traumatized teenage killing
machine x-23 on board he encouraged her
murdery tendencies rather than helping
her reform which went against the
Wolverines wishes and that of course
earned them a good old Logan punch to
the face prove it Yuri and naturally
Cyclops disavows any knowledge of
x-force of actions until he's caught
red-handed by the rest of the x-men and
it
far from the last time Cyclops would be
a dangerous extremist he brought Phoenix
back over the years the x-men of Delta
have more than their fair share of
ridiculously powerful beings but few of
their foes match the devastating Phoenix
force Cyclops didn't just deal with this
cosmic firestorm on numerous occasions
he basically married the woman who was
possessed by him but despite enjoying
far too much face time with a creature
that once destroyed an entire populated
world out of spite Scott Summers decided
to welcome it back to earth a join the
Avengers vs. x-men event the Phoenix
force breaks apart and chooses to join
with him and for fellow mutants but it
turns out that just one part of the
Phoenix force isn't enough so he steals
some from his on-again off-again
girlfriend Emma Frost making himself
nearly omnipotent insane with power
Cyclops goes full Dark Phoenix and tries
to kill pretty much everyone in the
penultimate issue the old true istic
professor eggs tried to help Cyclops
escape his cosmic power trip but got
declined forcing Xavier to lay the
psychic smackdown on him unfortunately
even an omega-level mutant like
Professor X is no match for the
intergalactic might of the Phoenix and
he's absolutely totally murdered by
Cyclops all of this even before he's
taken over by the Phoenix force so he
can't even really blame the alien entity
for being a jerk back in the end he
stripped of his powers and Ascot winds
up in prison moaning about his public
image because it's all about him right
from hero to radical merging himself of
the corrupting Phoenix force and having
it literally punched out of him would
probably be enough to make most
superheroes go cold turkey for a while
but Cyclops never seems to learn his
lesson many readers agree that the
downward spiral began with 2000 x-men
number 97 when he merged with apocalypse
but things only got worse after the
Phoenix thing in Avengers vs. x-men
consequences magneto and his crew bus
Cyclops out of Superjail the x-men then
goes on to the Clara mutants revolution
threatening anyone and everyone with the
wrong end of an optic blast in the
months following his death in Death of
eggs summers even inspires a crew of
brutal mutant thugs to carry on his
genocidal uprising I'm not so merry band
but I've calls themselves the ghost of
Cyclops you guys Cyclops isn't just a
he's kind of a full-fledged war criminal
and that includes an earlier incident
from secret invasion where he
intentionally infects an invading force
of Scrolls with the legacy virus which
is incredibly bad news and had the
potential to spread just about
everywhere very quickly aren't there
like laws about this kind of thing he
invited war from beyond the grave
when Cyclops discovers that a weird fog
has killed the mutants of Muir Island
during the death of X storyline
including multiple man Jaime madrix
fingers are immediately pointed at the
Inhumans and their transformative
Terrigen mists in an effort to destroy
the mutant blighting mists Cyclops
recruits a small army including a
chemical whiz kid in named alchemy who
pretty much wants nothing to do with the
mutants war and ends up getting killed
while neutralizing just one of a few of
the toxic fast clouds at the end of the
battle Cyclops is killed by black bolts
ridiculous singing voice becoming a
martyr for everything wrong with the pro
mutant cause except Cyclops wasn't even
alive at the time he was killed by the
mutants plague before the first issue
even ended and from then on he was only
a deranged psychic projection created by
Emma Frost
sadly dead men have no PR departments so
it's easy to understand why so many
people ended up hating Cyclops
but his worst crime of all he's named
Cyclops and he has two eyes what a
freakin liar thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you're loved too
[Music]
you